hey guys it's Justine and today we're
unboxing a new accessory for my iPhone
14. this could also be accessory for any
smartphone but since I did just get the
iPhone 14 I'm going to celebrate good
times by opening up the brand new DJI
osmo mobile 6. now with the new iPhone
14 it has this built-in action mode
which is already super stable so they
basically are like hey you're not going
to need a gimbal but with that action
mode there is a slight crop so with this
you will be able to shoot in 4k and yes
you will have a gimbal but I love the
DJI osmo models because they're always
so light I always love using the DJI
osmo as an accessory to my iPhone mostly
because it does have a lot of these
really great shots that you can set up
without needing another person like I
could basically film everything myself
there's gesture control there's tracking
and I'm so excited to open this up and
test it out
foreign
stabilization we've got a quick launch
portable and foldable active track 5.0
built-in extension rod and there's some
easy tutorials and one tap editing I
love the DJI software because they
always have really great AI editing and
they've got a lot of these little quick
tutorials that will give you some shots
that you can set up to automatically
make you a small little video edited to
Perfection we've got a little pull tab
now that's nice
I was ready to get my knife out
and here it is
launch I like that so when you unfold it
it automatically starts up and is ready
to go although I wasn't ready yet so
um I'm just gonna turn it off for the
second here's our phone mount nice nice
love to see it and it also comes with a
tripod this is such a key for people who
are doing a lot of solo shooting solo
travel because you could set up all
kinds of really cool shots that
otherwise would be almost impossible to
do with just a tripod
oh a little carrying pouch
nice a USBC cable for charging I'm gonna
put everything in my little bag just to
see how it fits oh my goodness I can put
everything in there I guess it was
planned that way so this has a three
axis stabilization active track 5.0
quick launch shot guides gimbal mode
switch it's portable foldable with a
built-in extension rod and a side wheel
for focus and zoom so let's have an
extendable rod
to give you a little more I guess length
when you're shooting so I've been doing
a lot of Apple watch reviews and I've
been filming some of them by myself on
the trail so this would be really great
to kind of get those little feet shots
if I'm like over here running trying to
get my feet running and then a little
wider angle out here
maybe a little side shot over here I'm
just picturing it now but yeah this is
cool
this is also nice if you attach this to
the tripod so you can have a nice decent
size tripod
just like that all built in this is the
magnetic
that was fast a little phone clamp and I
like this because a lot of times when
you have your Gimbal and stuff on here
you sometimes want to remove your phone
and then you just
go like that it must know that I'm ready
to record some tick tocks so the app is
downloaded I do have to update the
firmware but it's giving me a little
tutorial of how everything works so it's
showing you how to record a video by
pressing the record button
great recording has started to stop
recording
press the stop recording button
oh active track to track a subject there
we go excellent I've learned how to
track a subject there you are you're
moving you're moving and grooving press
switch button three times to switch to
photo mode oh
took a photo took a photo well done you
have taken a photo wow we're so skilled
this is great we're still tracking One
Tap turns us back there two Taps
portrait landscape switch here's ours oh
my God the zoom wheel is so cool look at
this
wow here's manual focus mode check that
out manual focus okay this is cool this
is freaking cool
[Music]
automatically launches up pop on our
phone and we are good to go we got so
fast I think the quick launch might be
one of my favorite new features the
first thing that I want to do is do the
tracking because obviously if I'm out
shooting by myself and I want to have
some movement in my shots doing the
tracking is key we're now on the front
facing camera active track is already on
okay I'm going to trace myself that's my
face we're tracking let's hit record
[Music]
like look at you a totally cool music
video like this
self-shot PGI osmo mobile six in the
house so yeah of course I'm a huge Tick
Tock fan I love shooting vertical
content so let's just flip this to a
little vertical action I'm going to
trace myself got that face in there
and we're going to shoot this in
vertical oh I'm going to use this so
much for tick tocks like you don't even
know
you don't even know
I haven't done a cartwheel in so long I
think I literally pulled every single
muscle and ligament in my body I See
Stars oh God I'm dizzy now that I got
the first one out of the way
oh the talent is a plenty so for gesture
control you either do a peace sign or a
palm you use Simple gestures as shown to
take photos and video I like that okay
it's a state within two meters of your
phone let's try a gesture control peace
there goes three two one
it's recording
yeah Palm to stop
if anybody knew what kind of magic was
happening over here you would be lining
up to see this so I'm gonna test out how
steady this is so we're gonna do a
little running around here I go
look at me running
oh it's so steady it's so stable
so steady
watch this
oh
here we go
[Music]
this is so stable
okay I'm gonna get myself I'm gonna
track my face see how that does when I
run now it's definitely keeping me in
frame that I'm still running
it's great this is great now this is the
shot that I've been wanting to get for
some of my Apple Watch review videos I
want to get this running shot now with
the new Zoom
I'm going to do the ultra wide zoomed
Ultra wide and then I'm going to hit
record
we're recording here we go
[Music]
okay let me see what it looks like let
me see let me see oh my God this is
exactly the shots that I've been trying
to get dude I'm so hyped right now this
is another cool little mode this is the
spin shot so basically what you're going
to do is you're going to rotate the
joystick a little and it's going to give
you this cool little spin shot
look at that
all right now we're going to test out
the story mode so basically you can
choose from a bunch of these different
little stories I'm going to choose
modern city so when we start this we've
got all of these options and it shows
you how many seconds and what to shoot
so we're going to follow the directions
and get ourselves a little AI story and
see what it looks like
foreign
[Music]
we just made right now and it reminds me
of like a 2018 I don't know maybe like
2002 I'm not sure what date but like an
MTV Music Video intro like to like what
is it TRL or something like that's what
this reminds me of but it's cool because
we literally did nothing like we shot
those shots and then it automatically
made it into a little movie for us
that's pretty cool so now we're going to
shoot a clone Me piano so I can kind of
see
where I'm at okay let's hit that
okay I gotta I gotta get in the shot I
think this is too low just a thought why
are you making me go so low
so here's my piano clone me I've been
cloned three times
I wonder if they're available
For Hire there's this cool app called
light cut which will directly connect
with your DJI osmo and I love that this
has this one tap edit so basically you
can choose your files it'll
automatically edit some content for you
together and we can go into here into
the Inspire cam this is so fun this will
give you a lot of inspiration on things
to shoot so if you are going for a walk
you can click the take a walk so it has
all of these templates and you basically
just follow the storyboard and it'll
automatically create you a vlog I feel
like this is really great for beginners
people who have maybe never made a video
or a vlog before it kind of shows you
how to make a story out of seemingly
just a simple thing like going for a
walk so this is telling me to shoot a
tree
guess what we've got a tree I'm gonna
hit record and I'm basically just
following what they did and kind of
putting my own little spin on it so you
start a new project this gives you the
ability to add in some shots that you've
already filmed so when you select those
you can go in select some of your
content already and it will edit
something together for you and you won't
have to do much of anything really so
that's another fun app and a different
way that you can start using the DJI
osmo mobile 6. if you guys want to get
more information about the DJI osmo
mobile 6 I'll put a link in the
description I really think this is great
for mobile vloggers for people who may
not have someone to help them shoot the
tracking the gesture control you're able
to basically have a full camera studio
right here inside of this gimbal one of
my favorite features on this though is
this Zoom like to be able to zoom in and
out so quickly is honestly a game
changer like yeah you could do that on
the touch screen but if I was filming my
feet I wouldn't be able to zoom in and
out that way I actually wouldn't even be
able to get that shot because my arm
would be I'd be running like this
not ideal I also like that the zoom
wheel also doubles as Focus control so
you'll be able to get some more precise
shots if you do want to be able to go
into manual control for the focus so all
in all I'm pretty impressed with it I
had a lot of fun checking this out and
again Link in the description if you
guys haven't already please subscribe
hit the Bell to be notified when I post
new videos and check out some more of my
videos here on the end screen
[Music]
do you think they want it do you think
you want to try it out hey boys check it
out check it out now